C'est un brouhaha permanent.
Toute la journée,
le centre ville de Calcutta
est bloqué par les embouteillages.
Pour le désengorger, le maire
en a interdit l'accès aux camions.
Ils ont rapidement été remplacés
par des milliers de bras,
de jambes, de tricycles, d'hommes,
qui trouvent là un moyen de survivre.
Mais à quel prix ?
Allez, allez, avancez !
À Calcutta, les hommes
ont pris la place des bêtes.
Les plus gros chargements
sont convoyés par ceux que l'on appelle :
les hommes chevaux.
On tire quatre tonnes là.
Il y a quatre tonnes
de marchandises sur le chariot.
Entre les hommes chevaux
et les voitures la bataille est rude.
C'est à celui qui passera le premier.
Calcutta compte
16 millions d'habitants.
La troisième ville la plus
peuplée d'Inde est une fourmilière
qui reflète l'état du pays.
En plein boom économique,
mais toujours très pauvre.
Toutes sortes de petits métiers de
la débrouille font survivre la population.
Du presseur de jus de canne,
au plus surprenant :
les cureurs d'oreilles.
Dans les campagnes,
l'argent a l'odeur du danger.
Ces adolescents jouent les équilibristes
pour voler le charbon qu'ils revendent.
On attaque entre trois
et cinq camions par jour.
Allez, allez ! Ramassez !
Gommer ses peurs
pour nourrir sa famille,
un art qui s'enseigne
de père en fils chez ces hommes.
Ils sont chasseurs de cobras.
Pour nous le cobra c'est sacré.
On vit, on mange, on boit, on dort cobra.
À Calcutta, le seul moyen de transporter
de grosses quantités de marchandises
est de faire appel
aux hommes chevaux.
Ils sont quelques milliers
à se partager le marché.
Tiens, prend le bon de commande
pour ce chargement
et il y aura aussi celui-là à faire.
OK ?
- OK.
Taj dirige une petite entreprise
d'une vingtaine d'hommes.
Il n'a pas encore les moyens
d'acheter une charrette,
alors il la loue 1€ par jour.
C'est moi qui suis
responsable de tout.
Surtout en cas d'accident.
Quand ça arrive, je dois m'occuper
d'amener mes gars à l'hôpital.
Mais aussi de la marchandise, du chariot.
Allez !
Poussez, poussez !
Les hommes entassent sur leur chariot
en bambou des cadres de vélo,
des gens, des vis,
du riz et des épices.
En tout, quatre tonnes de marchandises.
Allez, on lève, on lève, on lève.
Allez les gars,
mettez-y de la force.
Trois hommes tirent devant.
Deux poussent à l'arrière.
Ils ont six kilomètres à parcourir
pour rejoindre leur point de livraison
où stationnent les camions.
Allez, on avance.
Avancez, avancez.
Allez, tirez !
Une fois le convoi lancé, Taj, leur patron
devient leurs yeux, leur ange gardien.
Allez, double !
Allez, allez !
Mon travail, c'est de gérer les gens
et la circulation autour du chariot.
Il faut éviter de créer
des embouteillages.
Je parle aux gens, je fais
de la place pour les véhicules.
Nous, on est pressé.
Le chariot est lancé et
on doit livrer le plus vite possible.
Allez les gars !
Vas-y, avance mon frère,
à toi de passer.
Vas-y avance aussi.
C'est plus dur devant ou derrière ?
C'est beaucoup plus dur
pour ceux qui tirent à l'avant.
Arrêtez !
C'est éreintant, je suis crevé.
Ça demande un tel effort physique,
tu n'imagines même pas.
Et parfois, on se blesse.
On se blesse aux jambes.
Oui, la marchandise
peut nous tomber dessus.
Le plus difficile
pour les hommes de tête
est de retenir les quatre tonnes
de marchandises dans les descentes.
Doucement, doucement.
Attention, retenez-le.
Doucement.
Il reste quatre kilomètres.
Vous faites combien
de trajets par jour ?
On en fait deux en général.
Les hommes chevaux méritent
leur réputation d'hommes de force.
Ils ont parcouru
six kilomètres en deux heures.
C'est ici qu'on livre la marchandise et ce
sont les camions qui prennent le relais.
C'est comme ça que ça marche.
Les camions ne peuvent pas entrer
dans le centre. Alors, ils attendent ici.
Tous ces hommes viennent du Bihar,
l'une des régions
les plus pauvres de l'Inde.
Prenez-en un chacun.
Tiens, c'est pour toi.
Quand l'un d'entre eux
est à bout de force,
il est immédiatement remplacé
par un autre homme de sa région.
Comme Bindeshwar.
Ce paysan de 39 ans n'arrivait plus à
nourrir sa femme et ses quatre enfants.
Je suis extrêmement pauvre
et je n'ai pas trouvé d'autre travail.
Je n'ai pas le choix,
c'est pour ça que je fais tout ça.
J'ai cherché autre chose,
mais je n'ai rien trouvé.
Donc j'ai commencé
à travailler avec Taj.
Ma vie maintenant,
c'est ce foutu chariot.
Au moins,
on gagne bien notre vie.
C'est un boulot vraiment dur,
mais c'est bien payé.
Bindeshwar gagne
environ 160€ par mois.
30€ de plus que
le salaire moyen en Inde.
Dans les campagnes, ce salaire,
beaucoup d'hommes sont loin de le gagner.
Pourtant, ils prennent
des risques encore plus élevés.
À Samsi, une centaine de familles
vivent encore d'un métier qui demande
beaucoup de sang froid.
Les hommes sont chasseurs
et charmeurs de serpents.
Attends, regarde.
Regarde, comme ça.
Fais comme ça.
Tu as vu ?
Allez vas-y,
mords-moi si tu peux.
Ali, le chasseur
le plus expérimenté du village
enseigne au dernier de ses
six enfants comment charmer le cobra.
Il en va de la
survie future de la famille.
J'habitue déjà mon fils
de trois ans aux cobras.
Comme ça, il pourra faire
des spectacles dès l'adolescence.
Le venin du cobra
provoque la mort en quelques minutes.
Celui du cobra royal est tellement toxique
qu'une seule morsure
peut terrasser un éléphant.
Il n'y a pas
de risque pour mon fils,
sinon je ne le mettrais
pas si près du serpent.
Je sais exactement
à quel moment il va attaquer.
Et il attaque
seulement quand on l'agresse.
Là, le cobra est calme.
Il prend le soleil.
Mon fils est calme aussi, il apprend.
Ça lui donne du courage
et de la confiance en lui.
Il y a encore six ans,
Ali et les villageois gagnaient
bien leur vie avec les serpents.
Ils vendaient le venin
au laboratoire qui fabrique l'antidote.
Toute la communauté
se partageait les gains,
mais l'État a repris
à son compte le commerce du venin
et interdit de capturer,
détenir et de charmer des cobras.
Dans un recoin du village,
les restes de la grande époque.
Vous voyez ces cages ?
Elles étaient remplies de cobras.
Tout ça, c'est fini.
Notre métier est mort.
Nous, les charmeurs,
c'est le cobra qui nourrit nos familles.
On n'a même plus l'autorisation
de vendre au gouvernement l'antivenin,
alors qu'on sait le fabriquer.
Et c'est grâce à ça qu'on vivait.
Chaque fois que je vois ces cages vides,
je n'en dors pas de la nuit.
Ils ont tout gâché.
Ils ont brisé nos vies.
Si la police l'arrête avec des serpents,
Ali risque une forte amende,
voire de la prison.
Hé petit bout,
tu veux du thé ?
Attention, c'est chaud.
Mais avec six bouches à nourrir,
il a depuis longtemps bravé
l'interdiction du gouvernement.
Cette nourriture dans nos assiettes,
c'est grâce aux spectacles
avec les serpents que je peux l'acheter.
Il y en a déjà pas beaucoup.
Et si j'arrête,
ma famille meurt de faim.
Je ne sais rien faire d'autre
de toute façon, comme tout le village.
Et si on ne peut plus exercer
notre art, il restera deux solutions :
aller mendier ou prendre
les armes contre le gouvernement.
Ali et les hommes du village
en ont choisi une troisième :
continuer de chasser au nez
et à la barbe des autorités.
Ils sont une dizaine d'hommes
ce matin à aiguiser leurs bêches à cobras.
Quand ton père part à la chasse,
tu as peur pour lui ?
Non, peur de quoi ?
Peur qu'il se fasse
mordre par un cobra.
Impossible, c'est le meilleur.
Messieurs, notre destin
est entre nos mains.
Souhaitons que la chasse soit bonne.
J'espère que vous n'avez pas le ventre
vide, car il va falloir creuser dur.
Dans les rizières
qui entourent le village,
la récolte bat son plein.
Les rongeurs y pullulent,
attirant sur eux leurs pires prédateurs.
Les cobras chassent les rats
jusque dans leurs terriers.
Il y a des traces,
je vois des traces.
Là où passe le cobra,
il laisse une empreinte dans la terre.
Tu la voies parfaitement ici.
La trace est fraîche, ça signifie qu'il
est passé par là il y a peu de temps.
Sans cela, impossible
de pister le serpent.
Cette terre est dure
comme de l'acier.
Ali dirige la chasse.
Il intervient seulement
pour capturer le serpent.
Les hommes s'épuisent depuis 40 minutes,
lorsqu'une mue de cobra apparaît.
Mais Ali sait
que l'animal est déjà loin.
Il a filé par là
ou déjà là-bas.
La chasse est partie
pour durer des heures.
Regarde là.
Il n'y a pas
quelque chose sur le côté ?
Il y a un serpent là, c'est sûr.
Regardez, il est là.
Poussez-vous, poussez-vous !
Je vais l'attraper.
Recule, recule !
Attention, il va attaquer !
Mais non, t'inquiète pas.
Laisse-le partir,
laisse-le partir.
Ce n'est pas un cobra,
mais il est quand même très venimeux.
Laisse-le, laisse-le.
Ce type de serpent ne regarde
pas les hommes dans les yeux
pendant les spectacles.
Ce n'est pas comme un cobra
que j'arrive à faire danser.
Allez, allons creuser.
Il faut qu'on attrape des cobras.
Le temps joue contre eux.
En fin de matinée,
la chaleur sera écrasante.
Les cobras s'enfonceront alors
profondément dans les galeries.
Pour Ali et ses hommes,
la tâche se complique.
À côté de Dhanbad
à la sortie de la mine de Kusunda,
c'est un western
des temps modernes qui se joue.
Les diligences ont pris
la forme de ces camions.
Et les bandits,
celle de cette bande d'adolescents.
Ils convoitent le chargement
transporté dans les bennes.
Ce n'est pas de l'or,
mais un minerai bien plus
précieux à leurs yeux : du charbon.
Arrête-toi ! Arrête-toi !
Allez, on se fait celui-là.
Sa première attaque de camion,
Bablu l'a faite avec
son père à l'âge de treize ans.
Dans sa famille, on est voleur
de charbon depuis trois générations.
À 18 ans, c'est maintenant
un chef de bande respecté.
Allez aidez-moi, on ramasse !
Venez m'aider.
En général, on se fait entre
trois et cinq camions par jour.
Pas plus que ça ?
Si il y a des jours,
on peut en attaquer le double.
On fait tomber
le maximum de charbon.
Si le camion est chargé à ras bord,
on remplit trois ou quatre paniers.
Dans la bande,
chacun a son rôle.
Les grimpeurs pillent le chargement.
Allez, allez, ramassez !
Les moins agiles
remplissent les paniers.
Comme Sajan, huit ans,
le petit frère de Bablu.
Et leur oncle, Indra.
Les jeunes font tomber le charbon,
moi je l'évacue.
Avant, je montais sur les camions,
mais maintenant la relève est là.
Moi, je m'occupe
plus que de le ramasser.
Par compassion,
la plupart des chauffeurs s'arrêtent.
D'autres ne ralentissent même pas.
L'autre jour,
un garçon a été tué ici.
Que s'est-il passé ?
Un camion été lancé à pleine vitesse.
Il a essayé de monter dessus
et puis il a été écrasé.
Ralenti, ralenti, arrête-toi !
Il y a beaucoup d'accidents.
Tu ne sais pas
quand ça va arriver.
Aujourd'hui, par exemple,
je pourrais tomber d'un camion.
Tu sais, à la moindre petite erreur
tu glisses, tu tombes et tu es mort.
Je me fais souvent peur, mais je n'ai
pas le choix. On n'a que ça pour vivre.
Certains jours,
le risque ne paie pas.
En deux heures, les petits voleurs n'ont
amassé que quelques dizaines de kilos.
Bablu décide
de changer de tactique.
Le seul moyen pour récupérer
un maximum de butin
est de mettre
la main à la poche.
Donne lui de l'argent !
Je lui donne 2€, ça va ?
Hé attends,
attends encore un peu.
Allez-y !
Allez-y encore !
Tu bouges pas!
Hé toi, tu ne démarres surtout pas !
C'est bon, c'est bon,
il ne bouge pas.
Allez, on continue !
La bande doit évacuer
le charbon au plus vite.
C'est la fin de matinée,
l'heure à laquelle passent
généralement les gardes de la mine.
Allez, ramassez tout ça, vite !
Ça, c'est une très belle prise, tu vois ?
Comme on a soudoyé le chauffeur,
on en a fait tomber beaucoup.
Maintenant, on va
ramener tout ça à la maison.
Et commencer à le faire brûler.
La colonne des gueules noires
prend la direction du village.
Un kilomètres de marche à pied avec 50
kilos sur la tête pour les plus costauds.
Maintenant on va trier
le charbon et le faire brûler.
Mais ce sont de très gros morceaux.
- On va les éclater à la barre à mine.
À l'état brut, ce minerai n'intéresse que
les centrales électriques ou l'industrie.
Pour en faire
du charbon domestique,
il faut le faire brûler
pendant de longues heures.
Des centaines de familles
vivent de ce commerce.
Peu à peu,
la fumée avale le village.
Mon rêve, c'était de faire des études
et devenir joueur de cricket.
Mais comme je viens d'une famille
très pauvre, je n'ai pas pu le réaliser.
Mon père faisait
la même chose que moi.
Il n'a pas pu me payer d'études
et m'a petit à petit appris ce boulot.
Depuis mon enfance,
je n'ai rien connu d'autre que
cette foutue poussière et cette fumée.
Ce village n'est répertorié
sur aucune carte.
Il n'a même pas de nom.
Officiellement, il n'existe pas.
Il s'est construit au fur et
à mesure que les gens arrivaient.
Plus de 1 500 personnes vivent ici.
Dans des maisons en terre.
Seule la famille de Bablu,
arrivée la première, il y a 80 ans,
vit dans une maison en briques.
Moi, je suis né ici.
Je suis né dans cette maison.
Toute sa garde robe
pend sur ce fil.
Le reste de sa vie
tient dans cette malle.
Je voudrais avoir une grande maison
pour que toute la famille
puisse habiter ensemble.
Que mes frères et sœurs
aient des chambres séparées.
Que ma femme et moi,
nous ayons une chambre à nous.
On n'a même pas de lit,
pas de canapé, rien.
Je rêve d'avoir une télévision
et un ventilateur.
Mais c'est impossible,
je suis beaucoup trop pauvre.
Je n'ai rien
de tout ça chez moi.
Le vol et la vente de charbon
permettent à Bablu
de nourrir
les dix membres de sa famille.
Mais le prix à payer est lourd.
La transformation
du charbon lui ronge la santé.
À Calcutta aussi,
les corps sont mis à rude épreuve.
Dans le quartier des commerçants,
les hommes chevaux dorment où ils peuvent.
Si on a chargé la marchandise la veille,
il faut surveiller le chariot.
On pourrait nous le voler.
Ça représente
des milliers de roupies
qu'il faudrait rembourser aux commerçants.
C'est aussi
pour ça qu'on dort ici.
Et c'est très pénible.
Regardez autour de vous.
On dort par terre,
il y en a partout, regardez.
De toute façon, aucun d'entre nous
n'a de logement à Calcutta.
Au petit matin,
parfois, la fatigue est telle
que certains
n'ont plus la force de charger.
Comme Bindeshwar.
Solidaires,
ses camarades ont pris le relais.
Tant que j'en ai la force,
je continuerais ce boulot.
Le jour où je n'en peux plus,
je rentre à la maison.
Mon rêve, ce serait d'acheter
un peu de terre avec l'argent gagné ici,
mais c'est très cher.
Voilà, c'est ça mon rêve :
un jour, retravailler la terre.
La fatigue de Bindeshwar a fait perdre
un temps précieux aux hommes chevaux.
Il est déjà 8 heures et demie.
Allez, dépêchez-vous,
on est très en retard.
Et ils ont interdiction de circuler
après 8 heures du matin.
Cela crée trop de problèmes
dans la circulation.
C'est parti, on avance !
Allez, bougez de là !
Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils foutent ?
Avant, il y avait beaucoup plus
d'embouteillages à cause des chariots.
Mais au fur et à mesure, les autorités
l'ont compris et ça s'est un peu amélioré
quand ils ont réglementé la circulation.
C'est une grande ville ici,
il y a un vrai problème avec ces chariots,
ça ne devrait plus exister
et encore moins circuler ici.
Le monde évolue partout et nous
on a encore des hommes chevaux.
Hé les gars, il y a trop d'embouteillages
ici, qu'est-ce que vous foutez là ?
C'est vous qui foutez la merde !
Vous bloquez tout le monde !
Mais pourquoi vous nous
emmerder comme ça ?
Détestés des chauffeurs de taxi,
ils sont aussi des proies idéales
pour quelques policiers sans scrupules.
Surtout quand ils ne
respectent pas les horaires.
Parfois, ils veulent même
saisir notre marchandise.
On est alors obligés
de payer un bakchich.
C'est vous qui payez
ou c'est votre patron ?
Bien sûr que c'est nous qui payons,
ça va directement dans la poche des flics.
Avancez, bon dieu !
D'ordinaire, leur journée
s'achève vers 18 heures.
Mais ce soir-là, les hommes
chevaux redoublent d'efforts.
Pas question de partir en retard une
seconde fois et risquer une forte amende.
On finit de le charger.
Comme ça on prend
de l'avance pour demain
et après on va aller
manger quelque chose et dormir.
La recette de la journée
est répartie tous les soirs
équitablement entre les cinq hommes.
Même Taj, le patron ne
touche pas plus que ses ouvriers.
Tiens, c'est pour toi.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai gagné 7€.
Ce n'est pas mal.
Et j'envoie
quasiment tout à ma famille.
La plupart de ces hommes ne font qu'un
seul vrai repas dans la journée, le soir.
Ça fait un mois
et demi que je suis là.
J'ai déjà réussi à envoyer
beaucoup d'argent à ma famille.
Ce n'est pas simple.
Parfois, je gagne 2€ par jour,
parfois quatre.
Le plus dur, c'est quand
tu ne gagnes rien,
parce qu'il n'y a pas
de marchandises à transporter.
Quand je gagne rien,
je ne peux même pas manger.
Moi, ça fait dix ans
que je suis ici.
Avant, je tirais le chariot aussi,
mais c'est fini, comme tu as vu.
Je m'occupe
de gérer la circulation.
Ce travail me tue à petit feu.
Le soir, je suis brisé.
D'ailleurs ma famille
ne voulait pas que je vienne.
Cette vie ne me rend pas heureux,
mais je n'ai pas le choix.
Les hommes chevaux
sont voués à disparaître.
Ils renvoient l'image d'une société
sous développée que l'Inde émergente,
tente de gommer aux yeux du monde.
La fournaise s'est abattue
sur les rizières de Samsi.
Il fait maintenant 35 degrés.
Ali et ses hommes
ont parcouru quinze kilomètres.
Et toujours pas de cobras.
Creusez, les gars.
Il y a deux galeries, regarde.
Oui, j'en vois une qui part à droite
et une qui part à gauche.
Il y a un cobra là-dedans, c'est sûr.
Mais il va falloir creuser dur.
Ça y est, je le vois.
Le soleil les éreinte,
mais il est un allié précieux quand
il s'agit d'éclairer la tanière du cobra.
Il est enroulé.
Allez les gars, creusez encore !
Comme ça, c'est bien.
En ma présence,
personne ne touche au serpent.
Ils vont s'écarter
et je vais le capturer.
C'est à moi d'affronter le danger.
Regarde comme il siffle !
Il est très énervé.
Enlève ta main !
Enlève ta main, il va attaquer !
Ali est face à un gros mâle
de plus d'un mètre 70.
Les Indiens l'appellent Naja,
cobra à lunettes,
à cause du dessin qu'il a dans le dos.
Poussez-vous,
laissez-moi l'attraper.
Tenu par la queue, le Naja n'a pas
la force de se relever, ni d'attaquer.
Par respect pour l'animal,
Ali se présente à lui.
Tu aimes bien danser toi, hein ?
Allez, danse pour moi.
C'est dangereux un cobra,
mais je n'y pense jamais.
Une fois capturé, je le considère
comme mon propre enfant
et je le traite comme tel.
Je joue avec lui,
je le nourris et je l'éduque.
Reste bien droit.
Voilà, reste calme.
Comme ça.
Dans les campagnes, les cobras font
des milliers de victimes chaque année.
Pourtant, les paysans
ne cherchent pas à s'en débarrasser.
Bien au contraire.
En Inde, ils le vénèrent comme un Dieu.
Le cobra est le gardien
des sources, des rivières et des lacs.
Il est symbole de vie et de fertilité.
Ils en ont un autre !
La chance leur sourit.
Celui-ci traversait
un champ à découvert.
En cas de morsure, le venin du cobra
paralyse les muscles en quelques minutes.
Les hommes comme
les bêtes meurent étouffés.
Il existe un antidote,
mais aucun chasseur n'en possède,
c'est bien trop cher.
Ali, à sa propre méthode,
il a déjà sauvé plusieurs vies.
En cas de morsure,
la mort vient très vite.
Quand un chasseur se fait mordre,
je lui fais immédiatement un garrot
et j'ouvre avec une lame de rasoir
l'endroit de la morsure.
J'extrait le venin
en pressant sur la plaie.
Ça arrête tout de suite
sa propagation dans le corps.
L'Inde compte une vingtaine
d'espèces de serpents venimeux.
On l'appelle serpent rat.
On s'en sert dans les spectacles
pour attirer les gens.
Tiens-le bien, tiens-le bien !
Attrape-le par la tête.
Selon Ali, le venin de ce serpent est
aussi puissant que la force qu'il dégage.
Même à quatre mains,
il est difficile à maîtriser.
C'est une bonne journée.
C'est le quatrième qu'on attrape.
Il y a des jours,
on a beau fouiller tous les trous,
on a beau retourner la terre,
on rentre bredouille.
On va pouvoir
nourrir nos familles.
Dieu nous a porté chance.
Par solidarité,
les quatre serpents seront donnés
aux familles dont les reptiles sont morts.
Dès demain,
Ali prendra la route.
Cobras et serpents rats,
hypnotiseront le public.
À la nuit tombée, la mine de Kusunda
prend des allures de volcan en éruption.
Chaque feu désigne une famille.
Comme celle de Bablu.
Toutes transforment le charbon brut
en charbon domestique.
Soyez vigilants les gars,
faites attention à ce que vous faites.
T'inquiète pas, on a l'habitude.
Toi aussi concentre-toi.
Quand le charbon aura entièrement brûlé,
il va passer de l'état brut
au stade de petits bouts.
Il faut le couvrir progressivement
et le laisser se consumer.
Dans quelques heures, ça sera prêt
et on laissera refroidir le tout.
Bablu brûle son charbon
tous les deux jours.
Il passe des nuits entières
à en respirer les fumées toxiques.
Au fil du temps, elles attaquent
ses poumons et ses yeux.
On tombe souvent malade,
alors il faut voir un docteur.
Comme je fais ça depuis des années,
c'est certain que ma santé
ne doit pas être très bonne.
Il va rester
combien de charbon au final ?
Là ? Moi, je dirais 400 kilos.
Non, il y aura 250 kilos à peu près.
Peu avant l'aube, Bablu est rentré
dormir quelques heures.
Loin des brasiers, il fait à peine
cinq degrés dans sa maison.
La nuit a été courte et glaciale.
J'ai mal partout.
Je suis crevé, mais il faut
qu'on aille bosser là.
C'est encore trop chaud.
Il va falloir le laisser
refroidir un peu plus.
On va m'amener mon vélo
et on commencera à charger les sacs.
Tu as vu comme ça a réduit ?
Et s'il reste des trop gros morceaux,
on va les éclater au marteau.
C'est un travail d'acharné, mais bon,
au moins on va gagner
un peu d'argent avec tout ça.
On va au moins remplir cinq sacs.
Rempli à fond.
Ça va nous faire 250 kilos en tout.
Ils ont cinq kilomètres à parcourir
avant d'atteindre Dhanbad,
surnommée la capitale du charbon.
Au fur et à mesure
qu'ils avancent, Bablu est nerveux.
Attention, il y a la police.
Aux yeux des policiers, Bablu n'est
ni plus ni moins qu'un voleur.
Il fait rarement de la prison,
mais le racket est monnaie courante.
Ce jour-là,
il passe sans encombre.
Voilà déjà une heure qu'ils poussent
leurs 250 kilos de charbon.
On fait ça plusieurs fois
par semaine, c'est épuisant.
J'ai mal partout là,
tu n'imagines même pas.
Mais bon, il faut continuer.
Le plus gros client de Bablu est un
petit restaurant de ce quartier pauvre.
Il lui achète la quasi totalité
de sa production.
Je le vend 2€ le sac.
C'est le moment que je préfère,
la récompense après beaucoup de travail.
Si un jour j'ai des enfants,
je ne voudrais pas qu'ils fassent ça.
Je ne voudrais pas
qu'ils travaillent aussi dur.
Je voudrais pouvoir
leur payer des études.
Difficile d'imaginer la descendance
de Bablu faire un autre métier.
Depuis trois générations,
tous les hommes de la famille
volent et revendent du charbon.
Dès les premiers rayons du soleil,
les charmeurs de serpents
sortent leurs reptiles.
L'animal a le sang froid.
Sans cette chaleur,
c'est la mort assurée.
La joie est dans toutes les maisons.
Dans quelques heures,
le spectacle commence.
Mon petit-fils aussi attrapera des
serpents comme toute la famille avant lui.
Il deviendra charmeur
de serpents et jouera de la flûte.
Lui aussi, il fera danser
les cobras dans les spectacles.
Comme mon grand-père l'a appris
à mon père qui me l'a appris,
je lui enseignerais notre art.
Notre vie d'artiste n'est pas sans risque,
ça reste dangereux.
Je connais plein de charmeurs
qui sont morts, mordus pendant leur show.
On est obligé
de prendre des risques.
L'attraper, le montrer,
crois-moi, c'est sacrément osé.
Dans quelques mois,
l'hiver s'installera.
Il sonnera le grand départ.
Les charmeurs de serpents partiront jouer
leurs spectacles dans toute la région.
Ali prendra la direction du Népal
où les montagnards sont généreux avec lui.
Dans ces autres contrées,
ils voient peu de cobras.
Le reste de l'année,
les saltimbanques donnent
une quinzaine de spectacles par mois,
dans les villages alentour.
Approchez, approchez,
venez voir des serpents !
Ce n'est pas une blague,
venez voir des cobras !
Des comme ça,
vous n'en avez jamais vu !
Allez, applaudissez, applaudissez !
Et vous pouvez
commencer à donner.
Allez, sors de là !
Doucement, doucement.
Attends, attends, calmes-toi.
Allez attaque.
Comment tu vas faire
pour me mordre, hein ?
Allez, réessaye encore une fois.
Soyez généreux,
mes frères et sœurs.
Allez donnez, donnez !
Des roupies, du riz et
on va vous montrer un gros serpent.
Regardez,
regardez bien ce serpent.
Allez, sort un peu de ta boîte toi.
Redresse-toi !
Voici un des pires
prédateurs de la jungle.
On l'appelle le King Cobra.
S'il vous mord,
il vous réduit en poussière.
Instantanément.
Et maintenant,
je vais vous jouer de la flûte.
Je vais ouvrir toutes les boîtes
et les cobras vont danser pour vous.
Merci l'ami, il me donne
40 roupies, 40 roupies !
Allez, encore !
Regardez, encore 10 roupies.
Allez, qui d'autre ?
800 000 familles vivent
des spectacles de serpents en Inde.
Une tradition vieille de dix siècles
que l'État, comme pour les hommes chevaux,
tente de faire disparaître
au nom de la modernité.
Ce jour-là, Ali a gagné 6€
et un kilo de riz.
De quoi nourrir sa famille
pendant quelques semaines.